now on the public health front speaking
of health and human services
the left is still pushing these
ridiculous lock down orders
i think i have now heard the most
coherent pro-argument lockdown
from this entire many months-long fiasco
this comes from a public school teacher
she was driving down the street in her
car and i i felt she articulated this
better than just about anybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
wow very persuasive very very persuasive
this is who is teaching our students i
actually do think it's
exactly as persuasive as everything
newsom or cuomo or any of these other
people say
at least she's being honest about how it
has no basis in
rational thought and it's just purely
emotional
getting back to our prior discussion
there's this
silly holdover idea that the
liberal culture the secular culture is
neutral it's just neutral okay and we
can never
suggest we can never impose our views
on anybody else we conservatives and you
know the left is there
because if we impose our views then the
left is going to impose their views
i think they're imposing them i'm pretty
sure that's a public school teacher
i'm pretty sure she's imposing her views
if maybe she was having a bad day but i
think
that's pretty good evidence of what
you're getting in classrooms and you're
seeing this all around
the country it's not just on the stupid
lockdown stuff it's on the 1619 project
which is being taught
all around the country anti-historical
trash
that is designed purely to get students
to hate their
hate their country and sometimes
conservatives misunderstand this
because conservatives they they say look
we want education not indoctrination
those words mean basically the same
thing indoctrination comes from the
latin word
dochere which means to teach
you'll occasionally hear people say we
don't teach students what to think we
just want to teach them how to think
that's not possible all education is
coercive
you don't need to look like that crazy
teacher but you do need to teach people
things you can't teach people how to
think unless you teach them
what to think you can't teach people how
to think about mathematics unless you
teach them
the fact that two plus two equals four
and a student might come to you and say
well i wanna believe that two plus two
equals five well
you're not allowed to believe that you
ha i have to coerce you to believe
the two plus two equals four if i hope
to teach you how to think
the left gets this the left understands
that education is coercive
the right needs to get that too it's not
merely enough to say hey in addition to
your
blm curriculum where you're reading
kendy's stupid book
about anti-racism or you're reading the
1619 project which is
fiction but that's being presented as
history in addition to that would you
mind reading shakespeare
it's not enough to say that you have to
say don't read the 1619 project
take it out of the curriculum don't read
ibram kendi's stupid book
take it out of the curriculum by the way
you have to do that anyway because
there's only so much time
there are only so many semesters there's
only so many days in the week
we've got to get much more serious about
that
if we want to avoid that teacher
shaping the next generation which is
currently happening
[Music]
you